[Applause]
it was a day that felt miserable the
weather and the size of the defeat
Monday night's teasing glimmer of a
breakthrough and you made the
realization that she was going to lose
even more painful mr. speaker mr.
speaker
I beg to move it's the hope it kills you
okay you may say that but you should
hear John called Yonkers voice as a
result today the Prime Minister knew
defeat was coming first her voice gave
up on her and I'm certain that we've
secured the very best changes which were
available and then heard back benchers
the woman who once made a virtue of not
being probable now needed allies who
would follow her into the trenches they
weren't there so the noes have it
the noes have it grinding through the
days Theresa May has stubbornly clung on
perhaps driven by a vicars daughter's
sense of public duty she survived
confidence votes humiliation at the
ballot box and the worst defeat of any
sitting government ever does it want to
hold a second referendum at what point
note does an admirable ability to ensure
10 into sticking your fingers in your
ears her Premiership and her fragile
brakes that deal have weathered storms
before but this time it feels different
Sophie Ridge Sky News Westminster